friable sucré et souvent fait de ces
âmes le alva est un dessert à découvrir
très ancien le alva est un dessert
typique de la méditerranée orientale
composé de sucre et de taille ni la
fameuse crème de sésame classement à la
fin d'un retard soit la fourchette avec
à bord sa capitale c'est aussi simple
mais mais le dire au costco propriétaire
du café libanais cet état à montréal a
décidé de l'utiliser autrement dans un
latté cris sur un brownie
[Musique]
que dire ces spams en
jeu c'est drôle parce que là je goûte
abranis mellal voice est pas dominant du
tout du tout c'est vraiment par pur
hasard qu'on a créé ça
alors tu fais cuire tongs ornées oui on
le laisse faire 25 minutes en cuisson au
four après ça on le retire on ajoute la
lgv à qui est émiettée très finement
pour couvrir toute la surface et après
on lan font à nouveau pour cinq minutes
j'espère que la lgv à fond d'un petit
couteau la surface et prennent goût avec
le brandit la lgv a fait comme un agent
de crémant directement qui ajoute au
paraguay le alvac utilise mélodie est
disponible dans les épiceries
spécialisées en produits du moyen-orient
il provient principalement de turquie
d'égypte de jordanie de graisse et bien
sûr du liban on peut trouver plusieurs
variétés à base de pistaches et en à
base de chocolat elle va contre lyon on
y va on l'appelle valérie avec l'accent
et libanais pour le lat et mélodies
ajoute elle va directement dans le lait
ont fait mousser les à être l'alpha à
fondre qui ça le rend très onctueux
goûtons la deux
quand on goûte à elle va on pense que la
vie va être vraiment très sucrée mais au
contraire ça ajoute de la richesse au
lait à cause du gras qui se trouve le
real bat ce chocolat chaud en quelque
part au sitl le lait les très riches
avec l'allègement
l'idée du lattay venu parce que on
buvait notre lary avec les morceaux de
remy qui restaient en découpant le bruit
après on a dit pourquoi pas essayer de
faire la paix avec elle va probablement
qui va tomber sur des petits morceaux
pistache m n'est ce pas face aux prix
la cheffe johanna chéri est bien fier de
son petit café grec fils au bar mélina
sur l'avenue du parc à mourir on est
chez me lienhard je pense savoir
pourquoi sa santé
oui oui j'ai nommé la face à frey mélina
mercouri m'amuse c'était une grande dame
du cinéma grec c'est aussi la première
femme dans le parlement de la grèce en
grèce le alvin est une gourmandise vegan
très populaire surtout pendant le carême
orthodoxe le 202 à van gaal va à base de
tahini que on achète habitudes en
magasin mieux alva que tout le monde
peut faire à la maison qui est très très
facile qui lui des feux de semoule de
blé c'est une vraie c'est jay z très
mathématique c'est cette recette on va
jamais l'oublier c'est un deux trois
quatre
une tasse d'huile 2 tasses de semoule de
blé trois tasses de sucre et 4 tasses
d'eau j utilise de l'huile d'olive mais
on peut mettre nuit plus légères aussi
et là je vais mettre deux temps ce de
semoule
pissos c'est l'étape qui est très
important il faut pas sauter dessus il
faut vraiment venir
faire comme green seulement c'est ça qui
vous donner tout le but ça va la semoule
après quelques minutes elle va commencer
à avoir des arts ont droit
cinq minutes plus tard la semoule devenu
un peu colorée à absorber toute l'huile
johanna aime ajouter un petit plus avec
des amendes de la cannelle et du clous
de girofle moulu pour enfin verser le
sucre et l'eau
alors tout doucement
toutes les petites graines vont
commencer à absorber le sirop
et les épices ça va devenir répète comme
un pou d
quand votre salle d'école s'est très
nous voilà maintenant à mourir
et on est sûr fraudeurs au moins une
heure pour système
ok c'est beau cette femme c'est très
redouté
[Musique]
c'était intéressant à texture mais c'est
ça c'est extrêmement friable n'essaie
pas secs car je m'attendais à quelque
chose de circle prenons l'eau et le
sucre obtenir et bébés chaque grain
c'est unique
charleston
[Musique]